جواسيس الكريملين يتغلغلون من عاصمه
اوروبيه الى اخرى بحسب معلومات
استخباراتيه غربيه والوكالات التابعه لهذه
الدول تعرضت لاضرار خلال العام الماضي
اكثر من اي وقت مضى منذ نهايه الحرب
البارده الامر الذي ساهم في زياده التعاون
بين اجهزه الامن الاوروبيه وارتفاع وتيره
الاعتقالات في صفوف الجواسيس الروس ومن
هؤلاء الجواسيس الجاسوس البريطاني الذي
عشق بوتين وكرها بلاده ومواطن الماني
ينقبض عليه مؤخرا واتهم بالخيانه لمساعده
روسيا واداره الجواسيس في المراكز العليا
من جهاز المخابرات الالماني هذه الحمله
الشرسه التي شنتها اجهزه الامن الاوروبيه
تبدو وكانها فاجات روسيا واضعفت شبكه
الجواسيس التي طورتها موسكو لعقود في هذه
الدول
عمليات الطرد والاعتقالات اللاحقه ادت الى
تدهور قدرات الروس بشكل كبير بحسب صحيفه
واشنطن بوست وجعلت موسكو تسعه لتعويض هذه
الخسائر من خلال وسائل اخرى بدايه من
الاستفاده من المعابر الحدوديه وتدفق
اللاجئين لنشر جواسيس جدد وتجديد صفوفها
المنهوبه وصولا الى الاعتماد بشكل اكبر
على التجسس الالكتروني في محاوله من موسكو
لاعاده تشكيل شبكات التجسس من جديد في
اوروبا ولكن تبقى تلك المحاولات الروسيه
بحسب المسؤولين الامنيين في اوروبا فاشله
تماما سلطان العيبان العربيه